Yle Areena.
(Musiikkia)
Hei tehty paria. Olen kysynyt, onko Suomi nyt maailman onnellisin maa, niin koskinpa ihmiset on todella surullisia monista asioista ja uskon, että Suomi ei ihan onnellisesti.
Ei ihan onnellisen maiden listasta ole, että se on vähän keksitty juttu. Itse näen joka päivä työsseni ihmisiä ja on aika paljon kokemusta. Kiitos ja hyvää päivän jatkoa kaikille. Hei hei.
Ja lehti puhaltimista. Toki monet muutkin aiheet pääsevät vuorollaan keskiöön. Tällä kertaa jakson pääsiäistirehtöörinä toimii Koiviston Lauri. Yksi kanslainen toteaa, ettei totuuden puhujalla ole ystäviä. Toinen taas en kertoa, että yksin asuvat eivät ole loosereita. Ja ollaanpa myös koko pääsiäistä kieltämässä. Nyt Matti jatkaa ajankohtaisella aiheella.
No Matti, morjas. Morjas, morjas. Ja minäpä oman tätä kellon siirtelystä selvedään, että tunti sinne tänne, vaikka mitenkä on joskus aikanaan reissinut tuolla maailmalla niin paljon, niin kyllä se aikairo vaikuttaa niin paljon enemmän kuin tunti sinne tai tänne. Että sinulle on ihan sama, että kelloa siirtään ja kaksi siirtää vuodessa, niin ei hoitaa. No ei sinänsä haittaa, mutta tietysti se on sen järkevää, että tietysti se on aitoinen perus sen takia, että oli vaksit ja.
Näitä systeemejä, mitä tässä maailmassa enää ole, kyllä sen kello siirtelyn voisi lopettaa. No jos Suomessa lopettaisiin kellosiirto, niin haluaisitko enemmän valoisa aikaa aamun vai iltaan? Ja toisaalta sitten tunti sinne tai tänne, vaan olisi täällä mieltä, että onko kello kahdeksan aikaan valossa vai timeämpää. Ei se minulle ainakaan paljota millään lainkaan. Ei minulle käy kesäaika tai normaaliaikaa ihun väliin, mutta toivottavasti tässä täytetään.
Tää on vanha vanha jää, niin kyllä se on minusta vasta pois. Selvä juttu. Kiitoksia paljon näistä ajatuksista ja hyvää sanotaan jatkoa. Tamaa. Voittamoin viime aikoina meille tänne Kansanradion toimitukseen on tullut ehkä eniten yhteydenotto jo yhdestä teemasta. Kyseessä on kansanedustaja Päivi Räsäsen saama tuomio. Tässä siihen liittyviä kommentteja. Hyvää päivää Kansanradion kuuntelijat ja toimitus. En nyt sanoa, että.
Mikä hyvä päivä on. Veitä kohtasi tässä muutama tunti sitten suru uutinen. Päivi Räsänen oli saanut korkeimmalta oikeudelta langettavan tuomia. Tämä lisää itse sensuuria tekstikin ja rajoittaa sananvapautta. Suomi on aika lailla sellaisella kaltevalla pinnalla, jotta koska Suomessa nähdään näitä Tallinnin aikaa ja näytösoikeuden istuntoja. Tämä nyt voi sanoa, että.
Se oli jo niinku sen äiti tosin tämä korkeimman oikeuden päätös. Minä toivoisin, että esimerkiksi kokoomus ja keskustapuolue valitti puolensa. Ovatko ne länsimaisen vapauden puolella vai tämän riktatuurin ja auktoritäärin puolella? Se lupi olemaan niin kuin viime hetken. Minä toivon tätä, että Suomi herätpääs eikä vain vouskata.
Niin kuin tähän asti. Eipä tässä muuta.
No, kai soittelee Varsinais-Suomesta. Minähän olisin sitä mieltä, että tuo päiviräsääsen kohu on ihan turha.
Kyllä jokaisella kansanedustajalla pitää olla oikeus kertoa mielipiteensä. Ja uskon, että asiat ovat yleisesti, jotta Suomessa sallittuja.
Se on vähän turhan liioittelu antaa päiville sakot. Päivin pitää saada puhua niin kuin se sinne syödyssä tuntuu oikein. Ja meitä on paljon ihmisiä, jotka ovat samaa meiltä päivin kanssa. Me kaikki saamme sakot saman tien, että se on semmoinen tilanne. Kiitos. Hei hei.
No taata Jyväskylä liepäintä taas päivää. Tässä tämmönen oppimaton soittelee tästä päiviräsäisen jutusta. Onhan niin kuitenkin, että ihan tarkkaan ei tietä, mitä on tapahtunut. Mutta sen tien, että silloin aikojen alussa kun piti alkaa historiaa kirjoittamaan, niin oli papit ainoa, jotka osasivat kirjoittaa. Meni vuosia ja sitten säädettiin tämmöisiä sepustuksia aikaiseksi. Ja moneen kertaan korjattu ja uusittu ja veivattu. Eihän tämmöisitä kannata.
Kukaan ei tiedä, mitä alkuun tapahtuu. No nyt minä tiedän, että me siirrymme seuraavaksi nauttimaan näkemyksiä, jotka liittyvät edellisten ohjelmien teemoihin. Ennen puheluita tämä sähköposti sunnuntaina. Kaksikymmentätoinen maaliskuuta rouvaa epäili, miten lääkityksen käy, jos joutuu sairaalaan. Tiedoksi vain, että heillä näkyy tiedostoissa asiakkaan lääkitys ja siellä kyllä annetaan omat lääkkiä.
Läkeet asiakkaalle oikeaan aikaan, joten pelko pois. Näin lukee sähköpostissa, jonka on lähtenyt, että esimerkki kokemusta on. Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radiot yle.fi ei kansanradio. Lähä aikaa sitten joku ehdotti Kansanradiossa, että palattaisiin siihen, että kerjääminen ja kaupustelu kielletty semmoinen kultti kerrostalossahan oli aikanaan. Ja nythän sitä jo vuosiin.
Että palattaisiin siihen. Olen täysin samaa mieltä, mutta kun nykyään näin melkein kaikissa kerrostalossa tuo ulko ovi on siis lukossa, niin sen piltin voisi laittaa siihen ulko ovelle jo, että kerjääminen ja kaupustelu kielletty. Ja eikös ne ole sama asia? Näin ehdotti kansalainen. Lähteemään Jukka tai Turustamaan. Ei viime Kansanradiossa kyseltiin vähän, miten suhtaudutaan kuolemaan.
No mulla on semmoinen henkilökohtainen suhtautuminen, sanotaan semmoinen 65 vuotta aikaa, kun maaseudulla asuin, kun siellä joku vanha ihminen kuoli, kun mun isä oli semmoinen laulomiehiä. Siellä oli semmoinen tapa, että kolme neljä yleensä miestä lauloi silloin kun se vainaja kuetti ja nostettiin harkkuun. Me oltiin siellä sitten aina katsomassa tietysti tielle pojat. Ja kotona on paljon sillain keskusteltiin kuolemasta, että isä ja äiti jutteli, että
Se ei nyt varmaan enää kauan elää kun se on niin vanha joku naapuli että se pidettiin ihan silloin jo luonnollisena kun ihmisen vanhenee sen kuolleen ettei siinä mitään ihmeellisempaa ollut.
Mutta tänä päivänä on se kun ihmiset ei enää kotona kuole yleensä, ne on sairaalassa tässä vanhainkorissa ja jostain syystä sitten et se ei oo niin kauhean yleistä et vanhemmat keskustelee nuorten kanssa että miten kuolemaan pitää suhtelua.
Se on kyllä valitettavaa että kyllä mä olen yrittänyt omille lapsille selvittää kun ne vähän kasvavat että se on yks osa elämää. Ei siihen vaan pitää suhtautua että näin se on sinnyttä ja kuollain et enkä pitäis kun skoulussa enemmän keskustella siitä sit teillä ei kotona niihin pystytä. Ei muuta moi.
Tervehdys täältä Pirkanmaalta haluaisin vastata siille rouvalle joka nosti esiin perintöveroa. Ensin hän sanoi että se on jo kertaalleen verotettu.
Rahaa mikä tietysti on totta samoin kuin lahjaveron kohdalla se yleensä se raha on kertaalleen verotettua. Näin on monen muunkin veron kohdalla että jos ajatellaan vaikka ajoneuvoista maksettavia veroja niin siinähän maksetaan myös samalla lailla ansiotuloissa jo saatua verotettua rahaa tai sitten arvonlisäveroon mitä maksetaan kaupassani. Samalla lailla niistä tuloista on jo maksettu verot lahja ja perinnön kohdalla on vaan se ero että se.
Tai perinnön saaja ei ole maksanut siitä veroja siitä rahasta mutta toki siitä rahasta on kerran verot maksettu. Toinen asia minkä haluaisin tästä sanoa varsinkin perintöveron kohdalla on se että perinnöstä kolmenkymmeneen tuhanteen asti niin se on verotonta eli niin kuin jo kohtuullisen perinnön saa ilman että tarvitsee maksaa mitään veroa.
Täällä on mullin kasvat ja haukuttu yksilö Pohjanmaalta. Hyvää päivää. Kuuntelin sitä ja.
Pohjanlihaa puutetta ja kyllä se menee aivan väärään suuntaan. Mehän olemme EU:n jäseniä ja se toimii aivan tämän tukipolitiikan turvin tämä maatalous- ja yleisen ruokatuotanto niin kunhan siitä nyt pari kolme vuotta niin EU lakkasi maksamasta tuottajille tuki ja yksivuotiaan vasikan kun tappaa niin siinä on tuet sitten ollut.
Kuitenkin jos Sony kasvaa kaksivuotiaaksi taikka härkä se on saanut raamit ja sen jälkeen kymmeneen ikävuotiaan asti kerää niiden raamien ympärille lihaa mutta kun EU lopetti sen lihan kasvatuksen yksivuotiaaksi eli elämää niin kuin väheksytään ja tuhotaan sille että mukaan vasikanlihaa on hyvä niin tässä sitä sitten nyt on.
No miten tästä tilanteesta eteenpäin?
oh meillä ne EU parlamentaarikot ja muut ja on jopa MPK:t ja tämmöset niin eihän tässä ole päätä eikä häntää että joku joka kasvattaa lihakarjaa niin se ei pysty kasvattaa et ne siitos on ja koska sille ei saa mitään tukia niin kyllä se siellä on se Brysselin suunnassa se on tämä asia ja yleensäkin se tuo elämän väheksyntä että niin yks vuosi
vuotiaana nitistetään nautaeläimet ja kukkopojilta niskat katkaistaan. Heti kun ne on kuoriintuneet, niin se on kyllä melkoista elämää haaskuuta. Kyllä tämä on se totuus, mutta totuuden puhujalahan ei ole ystäviä niin kuin Jeesuskin sanoo. Hei hei!
Terve! Minun mielestäni kuva ja ääni synkronisoituminen lakkaat siinä vaiheessa kun analogiset tv-lähetykset lopetettiin. Eli kyllä tämä on tätä uutta. Tämä on nyt niin hienoa ja niin hyvä, että ollaan nyt vaan tyytyväisiä, että sentään edes samaa minuutia aikana tulee sama kuva ja sitten ääni. Moi!
on veneitä, moottoripaatteita, eivätä kaikki isolla laivoilla siellä ajele. Kyllä laivoillekin on tärkeä merisää. Verinteinen välttämätön kuuluvat asiat. Ja ei ole mitään, että jättää merisääntä ilmoittamatta. Kansanradiossa äsken joku sanoi, että merisääntä ei tarvitsisi ilmoittaa, niin sehän on aivan pimeä näkemys. Kyllä merisääntä täytyy ilmeisesti tietää, mikä liikkuvat vesillä ja merilläni. Ja myös Saimaallakin liikkuvat isolla järvillä, niin siitä on hyötyvä tietää, minkälaista säätä on luvassa, joka ei liiku merillä eikä vesilläni. Ei se ymmärrä
että täällä halko piinoo.
Eläkeläinen Pohjanmalta. Ukraina on sotilaallinen uhka Suomelle. Kiitos.
Eikö voi näin tämä joulupukin tutkimaan naapurin toimestaneen harjoitusohjauksen Inarin järven jälkeen tuota lennättä mennä? Tällä se voisi kohti. No kiitos.
Siihen että hävittäjät lentää yli talon itärajalle päin. No tästä ei ole kauaa pitkää matkaa tuohon Venäjän rajalle. Olemme täällä entisellä Anjanakosken alueella ja Jyrinä ja Jytinä jatkuu jonkun aikaa ja onneksi palasivat sitten pois ja hiljeni tilanne. No olihan siellä jotain ollut uutisten mukaan mutta.
Toivottavasti ei mitään vakavaa tapahdu mutta on tuo sota ollut kauheaa. Nyt sen tajuaa itekin että kaikkea hyvää sinne ja toivottavasti me pysymme Suomi rauhallisena maana. Kiitos. Hei.
Venäjän tänne niin se on tämän tekniikan näitä ongelmakohtia joita yritetään kohenella ja lähtökohta on se että Venäjän tämän hetken diktatuuri on yksin ja täysin syyllinen ja saa sitä mitä on tilannut itse elämänsä pilanneet. Meidän ei pidä hötkyillä tämän asian kanssa.
Syytensä puolustamista koko Euroopan ja globalisaation puolesta jotta pysyisi hengissä. Toivotaan että mahdollisesti harhautuvat ja Venäjän diktatuuriin terrorijoukkojen ehkä määrään suuntaan jotenkin harhauttamat ohjukset ja troonit eivät osu kohdalle. Näin ja hyvää sunnuntain jatkoa itsenäisestä Suomesta parasta radio ohjelmaa kuunnelle.
- Seuraavaksi siirrymme muiden politiikkapuheluiden pariin. - Täältä Oulusta lavonta-aamua. Lyhyestä vitsi kaunis. Itä eroaa Suomella ja muilla oikeilla kansanvalloilla demokratioon. Muualla hallitukset on kansaa varten, mutta Suomessa kansa on hallitusta varten. Kiitos, hei.
Ei vaan siirtymään sähköautoihin, kun nyt on tää bensain kallista. Eihän siinä mitään kun vaan naikkonen lupaa kuule valtioilta rahat sähköautoon, niin minä olen valmis vaihtamaan heti. Että se on sellanen juttu, että kaikki köyhät ei kuule pysty vaihtamaan sähköautoon. Sitäs siinä onkin. Muutenhan vaihdettaisiin heti. Eihän sille voi mitään. Jos ei kerran rahoja valtioilta saa, niin ei ole varaa vaihtaa sähköautoa. Voitapas järjestää jokaiseen köyhälle rahaa sieltä valtion kasvosta, niin saadaan sähköautot.
Minä olen varsinkin tehnyt kyselyn tuota nettiin ja nyt siellä on kolmea puoli miljoonaa ihmistä, jotka ovat sitä mieltä, että Alexander Stubbin pitää tukkia turpansa ja lopettaa lentämästä ympäri maailmaa ja höpöttämästä. Hän on terapöytin, pääministerin terapöytin. Minua hämettääkö Ruotsissa ja Amerikasta asti? Sukulaiset sanovat, että onko se se on? Minä sanoin, että se on Trumpi kakkone. Voi herra isä, ettäkö ihmiset tajuvat sota tavalla? Muutenkin sitä on jo minullekin tällä hetkellä tällä hetkellä.
Tässä minun gallupissa oli miljoonaa kaksisataa, kuusikymmentä, kuusitoisataa, neljasattaa kolmea ihmisestä sanoa, että mitä se lentää ympäri maailmaa ja viuhuttaa ja joka paikkaan se kaantuu ja puhuu on surullista. Mutta kiitos Kansan radiolle.
Kansalainen päivää. Tässä kun nämä ihmiset purnavat ja valittavat koko ajan, oppositio rakentaa koko ajan, mutta kansalaille tiedoksi, että vuoden päästä kun on vaalitkin melko lähellä ja valittaa uusi eduskunta, niin siellähän on.
Kansalaisillehan koettaa kissanpäivä. Näinhän tämä oppositio antaa ymmärtämättä. Kaikki tämä tekee väärintämään nykyinen hallitus. Ihan kaikki mittään se ei ussaa tehdä oikean muuten kuin mutta kissanpäivät koettaa kansalaisille. Ja sitten kun nämä linkman niukon pääministeri ja kepu on siinä, ihan nämä muu toivoisaa hyvä elle. Elikkä kansalaisille sataa pelkkää mannaa sitten. Näin oppositio antaa nyt on koko ajan tänne ymmärtää. Kiitoksia. Hei!
Tämän seuraavia eduskuntavaaleja ehdimme ainakin pysähtyä erilaisten sote-teemojen pariin. Nyt tällä kertaa tämä on hyvin laaja otsikko tuleville aatoksille. Audiomuotoisi ajatuksia edeltää tämä Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella lähdetty viesti. Terveydenhuollosta vaan sellaista, että nykyään ihmisten pitää itse ottaa selvää, mitä labrakokeita pitäisi ottaa ja soittaeko kukaan tuloksia vai kysytäänkö niitä.
Onko itse jostain, minne lääkäriin pitää mennä ynnä muuta? Tekoälyltä kun kysyy, niin se kertoo samat asiat kuin lääkäri, jos sinne joskus pääsee eikä tarvii maksaa käyntimaksuja. Kävin lääkärissä ja saman diagnoosin sain tekoälyltä. Siltä kun saisi vielä reseptinkin uusittua, niin ei tarvitsi vaivata terveydenhuoltoa. Tämän tekstin oli meille lähettänyt esimerkki Tekoäly ei tiuski. Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Jussi Etelä-Hohjemmalta hyvää keväpäivää, vaikkakin pihalla vähän tuulee ja tulee räntää, mutta siitä huolimatta hyvällä mielellä, vaikkakaan Suomen hallitus ei aja yhtään pienituloisten asiaa eteenpäin. Eli lähinnä nyt tällä kertaa soittelen yksineeläjien puolesta, koska heidän asiaansa on heikennetty vuosi vuodelta ja erittäin reteellä toiminnolla.
tämän hallituksen aikana porpolle ja purralle siitä kiitos, että he ovat pystyneet tähän heikentämiseen pienituloisten osalta. Kyllähän he hyvätuloisia ovat hoitaneet hyvään malliin. Mutta, kuten sanoin, olisikohan Suomen hallituksella tai eduskunnalla yhtäkään semmoista puoluetta, joka voisi luvata totuudenmukaisesti ja varmasti, että joku ajaisi yksin eläjien asiaa. Siihen kuuluu.
muun muassa opiskelijat, eläkeläiset, yksinhuoltajat ynnä muut, että ei ne kaikki ole loosereita, kuten minäkään olen, vaikka vaimoni on kuollut 28 vuotta sitten ja kuitenkin elän yksin ja oma kuten talossa, josta on toki vieläkin velkaa, mutta elämässä ollaan kiinni, vaikkakin tosiaan kuten sanoin niin elinehto ja hallitus voimakkaasti heikentää, että en tiedä mikä heillä on tarkoitus siinä. Eletään hyvässä toivossa ja kaikille hyvää kevääntolua.
- Ja kyllä se kesäkin sieltä tulee. Kiitos, hei hei. - No haluaisin tietää missä on lähinnä syöpäseulonta. Oli mikä syöpä tahansa seulonnassa. Miehinkähän mä pääsin? Ikä on 79 vuotta. Hei hei.
- No tämä on eräs eläkeläinen senior tältä Raisiosta. Mielestäni tupakan hinta on liian korkea. Ja jos ihmiset haluttaisiin saada lopettamaan tupakointi, -
niin kun tiini valmisteista pitäisi saada Kela korvausta. Kiitos. - No täältä Turusta Mommeli. - Hyvää päivää. - Päivä. Mä olen tänne Turkuun muuttanut sinne vajaan kaksi vuotta sitten. Puolentoista vuotta olin täällä asunut ja muutin Paihjoista tänne. Ja tälleen nyt pääsin hammaslääkäriin ollenkaan. Puolen vuoden odotusaika pitää olla. - Siis julkisella puolella? - Niin julkisella kyllä. - Puoli vuotta tuntuu pitkältä ajan. - No vanhalle ihmiselle se hehtii kupsaa.
Täältä jo, että kyllä pitäisi päästä kyllä aikaisemmin. - Ja olet ollut yhteydessä ja sieltä on sanottu että puoli vuotta vähintään menee.
- No niin tuohon luolavuoren tuota sinne hammaslääkäriin ei aikoja ole ennen. Eikö ole ihan kauhea pitkä aika odottaa niin kun vanha ihminen jo paljuu yli kahdeksankymmentäviisi jo on niin se kai kuolee sitä ennen jo pois siitä ettei tarvitse sitten antaa ollenkaan. Kun vielä tuntui se että olisi kiva että saisi hampata hoidettaa. - Kiitos kun soitit kansanradioja kerroit tämän. - Niin joskus vielä paranisi tämä aika. No kiitos.
- Joo hei.
Kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Kiitoksia ei muuta.
Minun mielestäni Västeli Orpo ja Porra heidät pitäisi erottaa yhdyskunnasta. Heidät pitäisi erottaa yhdyskunnasta. Miksi ajattelet näin? Kieltävät sosiaalisen median nuorilta. Kieltävät sosiaalisen median nuorilta. Onko näin tapahtumassa? On. Mihinkä tämä tieto perustuu? Minun lapsen lapseni en ole huomennut pahaksi kun hän ei saa puhelinta. Millä tavalla pahaksi? Hän on tekemässä kaikkia pahuuksia. Se johtuu siitä kun hän ei saa käyttää sosiaali- ja terveyspalveluita.
Kyllä.
...lapsellisia temppuja ja tehtäviä. Ja mitä niissä yleisesti ottaen katsojille tarjotaan hölmöjen tehtävien ohessa? Sekoilua, sikailua, valehtelua, pettämistä, parin etsintää ja niin edelleen. Tällaistako sirkushuvia kansa kaipaa? Yhdet ja samat julkisuuden kipäät henkilöt kiertävät ohjelmasta toiseen kuin karusellissa. Tällä tavoin luki kirjeessä jonka meille oli lähettänyt esimerkki. Tiedän että tv:n voisi saada.
Kansanradion voi laittaa kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postiaosoitteeseen Kansanradio pl79 000 24 Yleisradio.
Pirjo, olisin semmoista asiaa sanonut, että miksi muutettiin tuo radio-ohjelma kysy-tai vastaa? Keskiviikkoon vartin yli neljä, kun se oli ennen sunnuntana iltapäivällä. Nyt moni sanoo, että ei voi kuunnella kun tulee töistä.
Lapsille pitää tehdä ruokaa ja kaikki, että olisi kiinnostavia kysymyksiä, mutta ei niitä voi kuunnella yhtä aikaa, että sunnuntana iltapäivällä olisi ollut joutoaikka kuunnella. Ja se oli hyvä aika. Kiitos, hei.
Ei ehdiottaa siitä sitten itselle niitä numeroita? -Joo, ei niitä kerkiä ottamaan. -Selvä, kiitoksia ja hyvää pyhäpäiväjatkoa. -No niin, joo, morjes.
-Ja vaan hallikaiselle ja koivusalalle. Aivan kohta kuulemme aprilipäivätarinan, jossa siinä palataan myös vuosien taa. Ensinnä on kuitenkin aiva kertoa Kansanradion puhelinnumero. Se on 08-001-5564 ja puhelu on soittaajalle maksuton. Ja muistutuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello 12.30 alkaen tuossa numerossa vastaan tulee puhelinnumero.
Tota ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan. -No, tältä hämmeestä. Huomentapäivää. -Huomentapäivää. -Nyt kun toi aprilipäivä on tuossa lähellä, niin mä päätin joittaa ja kertoa tosi tarinan kymmenien vuosien takaa. Mä olin työelämässä ja lehdessähän, en sikäläisessä valtaehdessä, niin oli ilmoitus, että Katri Helena tulee esiintyy tuohon torin.
Minä kiireesti rupean hakemaan, ettenkö mä sais vaihtaa työvuorooni, että tykkään olla mukana. Jos hän on täällä Hämeessäkin, kukaan ei suostunut vaihtaa mulle työvuoroa, kun kaikki oli menossa. Katri Helena katsoo torille. Minähän jäin aika synkkänä sitten, kun en saanut vaihtoa, niin en saanut vaihtoa. Ja tuli seuraavana päivänä tämä Hämeen sikäläinen tää valtalehdi.
Se oli siellä, kun avataan lehti, niin heti seuraavalla sivulla lehdellä, että Aprilia, Aprilia. Se oli Abri Laus. Ja tiedättekö nämä, jotka vaihtovuoro? Siellä oli paljon muitakin eturivin ihmiset, niin mä tunnistin näitä henkilöitä, jotka gemotti siinä eturivillä ja toisellakin rivillä ja paljon tuttuja oli. Mä ajattelin, että passa.
Sitä olla hymyilevä ja naurava ihminen, kun tulevat töihin sitten seuraavana päivänä. Siis hyvin harvoin positiivista asiaa tulee kansanradiosta niin kuin Julki. Niin eikös tää on yksityisen henkilön positiivinen juttu, että. No tähän on juuri sellainen. Kiitoksia paljon tästä apripäivän muistosta. Ja heille kaikille hyvää. No, aprilipäivää sanotaan näin.
Kiitoksia. Hei hei. No niin. Moi moi. Aprilipäivästä askellaan pääsiäiseen. Kiitokset muuten kaikista pääsiäistervehdyksestä, joita meille toimitukseen on tullut eri kanavia pitkin ennen seuraavaa puhelua. Vielä yksi Vatsap viesti. Kuuntelemme säännöllisesti Kansanradion sunnuntaisin. Lähetysaika on muutenkin lyhyt, joten siirtäkää nuo oman runon puhujat omaan päiväänsä, jonka ilmoitatte etukäteen.
Eikä mielestämme ne kuulu tähän ohjelmaformaattiin. Näin voisimme kuunnella asiallistakin asiaa lyhyen lähetysajan puitteissa. Runoilla niille erikseen, joilla sepittämisen polttava kutsu. Kiitokset muuten hyvästä ohjelmasta. Tämän Vatsap viestin meillä on lähettänyt eläkeläispari Merilapista. Kiitosten lisäksi muistuksena, että Kansanradio on sekä tosikoiden että veitikoiden ohjelma, johon kuuluu.
Myös oleellisesti runot, kuten tässä seuraavaksi. Lasse, ole hyvä.
Myös joukolla muna pärjätään. Kyllä suklaamunilla pärjätään. Puput kaikki esille kaivetaan. Pajun risuja vaasiin laitetaan. Tiilas torstaita myös vietetään pitkäperjantai. Tulua siedetään. Jeesus listiin silloin avattiin. Vielä ranka lauantaina ehtettiin. Pääseisenä oli ylösnousemus. Jeesus.
Elossa katosi ahdistus. Myös toisena päivänä juhlitaan iloisesti. Päivässä nautitaan. Nauttikaa tekin ja hyvää päiväseettä toivottaa. Aallon laset kaikille. Moi.
Kansan radio jälleen viikon päästä. Uuraisilta van mummupäivää semmoisesta, että nämä lehtipuhaltajat ei ole hiekkaa eikä sepeliä varten. Niillä puhalletaan täällä ainakin niin, että hyvät autonkumppeet ovat mäsäännä tuolla parkkipaikoilla. Radiosta kuulin, että ne ovat laittomia puhaltaa, hiekkaa ja sepeliä. Ei muuta. Täällä urosilla kyllä tapahtuu kaikki muutakin semmosta, mitä ei saisi tapahtua. Ei kuntaa, ei tarvita mitään. Ehto.
Kerminen kevät alkaa, kun työ ja päivän lämpötila ovat plussalla. Kiitos. Hei.
Eipä siinä muuta. Kiitoksia.